I mean you're always looking for
something new to discover birth we
didn't know what we're going to find
when we started them on that day
multi-word is a pretty routine you know
you just keep finding more tunnels and
more tunnels but every time you get
lucky and you run into these discoveries
that being trapped there for thousands
of years
you just pop up into this huge void it's
like if you enter the Grand Canyon from
the side at night
everywhere you point your lies there
were animal remains of human remains
which is a pretty good day
eventually my friend planning to apply
to this cranium and all the sudden we
discover the most complete and the
oldest human remains found in America
haha
imagine the pressure with somebody say
okay you've got pick up the cranium of
the oldest human remains in America your
hands start shaking you know what
happened if you drop it you know you're
in the water and you're looking at this
cranium you could see this with dark eye
sockets have this feeling these eyes
have not seen anything since thousands
years ago you cannot travel him back and
time in the case of Naya we have more
focused skeleton the more amazing thing
is that you still have intact DNA that
researchers can extract from so that
helped you figure out the migration
history from humans into the America
when we go in this case with we think
they were doing this great exploration
but in reality the original explorers of
this tunnel
when I am and her people when I have a
bad day even on the jungle or at home I
compare it with what a struggle to go
and find water and food and shelters and
everything and they having to fight
animals you know they have to save it to
tag so for me it's easier if I have a
problem I just think about them and look
out my problems is over this is your
Negro and now you're the star of this
project and we all work to bring their
stories life so we understand a little
bit better about whether we come from
this is the earliest pre-colonial
shipwreck ever discovered